Now that we have seen flush stall and forwarding
as a solution for hazards in a pipeline let's do
a quiz to see if you know when each should
be used. Let us say that we have a five-stage
pipeline where the first stage fetches the instruction, the
second stage calls the instruction and reads the registers. The
third stage, the instruction does the ALU operation and a
branch is the result so we know where its going.
In the mem stage loads and stores access memory,
so at the end of this stage a load will
finally have a value. And finally the fifth stage writes
the result to the register. Here, we have some hazards.
First, there is a control hazard. After the branch
we fetch two wrong instructions; before we fetch the correct
multiply instruction in this case. So the red ones are
the ones that are fetched incorrectly. The question for you
is should we flush, stall or forward here? Put a check mark in each of these
three boxes depending on which one we do
here. Next, we have a data dependence where the
multiply is producing the R1 result and the
load needs to use that as the memory address.
Put a check mark in each of these
three boxes depending on whether we need to flush,
stall, or forward the value in this case. And finally, the load is producing the
value of R1, that this add needs to use, so the question for you is should we
flush, stall, or forward in this case? Note that in some cases, more than one of
these needs to be used for optimal performance.
To help you get started I'm going to tell
you that for data dependencies, as we said, we never want to
use flushing, so the real question is just should you stall or forward?